PROFESSOR: To mention,
most everyone did
extremely well on the quiz.
But I sense that there's still
some of you who have not yet
come to terms with
crystallographic directions
and planes, and you feel
a little bit awkward in
distinguishing brackets
around the HKL and
parentheses around HKL.
And there are some people
who generally get that
straightened out, but when I
said point group, suddenly
pictures of lattices with
fourfold axes and twofold axes
adorning them came in, and that
isn't involved in a point
group at also.
Again, a point group the
symmetry about point.
A space group is symmetry spread
out through all of
space and infinite numbers.
So let me say a little
bit about resources.
I don't know whether you've been
following what we've been
doing in the notes from
Buerger's book
that I passed out.
That was hard to do is because
we did the plane groups, and
he doesn't touch them at all.
So now we're back following once
again Buerger's treatment
quite closely.
So read the book.
And if you like, I can tell
you with the end of each
lecture, this stuff is on
pages 57 through 62.
The other thing.
As you'll notice, this
nonintrusive gentleman in the
back is making videotapes
of all the lectures.
These are eventually going to
go up on the website as
OpenCourseWare.
We were just speaking about
that, and it takes a while
before they get up, but I have
a disk of every lecture.
So if there's something you
didn't follow or a place where
I chewed my lines and you want
to go back over it again-- not
that that happens very often--
you are more than welcome to
ask me to borrow and borrow
the disk if you want
to review it.
So that's another resource.
And then I will regularly
throughout the term give
hard-copy handouts of some of
the things that we're doing,
particularly when it
involves geometry.
And when we move on to
three-dimensional geometry,
unless of the graphics is really
tight and precise, it's
hard to follow what's
going on.
So in that vein, one of the
first things I wanted to pass
out-- the only other
one for today--
is a demonstration that in fact
in the Group 23 all you
need is a single twofold axis
oriented along the normal to a
face and a single threefold
axis coming
out of one body diagonal.
And that gives you all
of the axes you are
going to get into 23.
So when this comes around, there
are number of steps that
you can perform letting the
axes work on each other.
And if you start with just the
single twofold axis and the
single threefold axis-- which
the symbol suggests is all you
need, there's only one
kind of each--
if you look at a cube along its
body diagonal, the twofold
axis that's coming out of one
face gets rotated into
directions normal to all the
other faces if you rotate by
120 degrees.
So the little diagram in the
upper right hand corner of the
sheet hopefully convinces
you of this.
Now we've got three mutually
orthogonal twofold axes and
one threefold axis coming
out of a body diagonal.
So the vertical twofold axis
swings that around by 180
degrees to give you another
threefold axis
along a body diagonal.
And I labeled that one
3 prime in the
middle diagram at right.
And then if you take the axis
3 prime and repeat it by the
second of the twofold axes
that we have along face
normals, that in the middle
diagram on the right hand edge
takes 3 prime and repeats
it to 3 double prime.
Then finally, the third twofold
axis that we generated
repeats the threefold prime
axis to the remaining
threefold axis along the
fourth body diagonal.
So the results start with one
twofold axis oriented along
the normal to a cube and one
threefold axis along the
diagonal of the cube, you get
axes coming out of all faces
and all diagonal.
And there's a staple on that
sheet for reasons that I don't
understand, but it there was,
probably on the surface of the
Xerox machine when I
went over there.
So let me now return to our next
step, and that is to add
what in the language of group
theory is called an extender,
a new symmetry operation that
can be added to a preexisting
group that will generate
new operations.
And let's see what sort of
theorems we need to describe
what we should look for and in
which particular orientation.
We've got these 11 axial
combinations, and these are
frameworks that we can hang
mirror planes on.
So let's look at a first
simple combination.
Suppose we have a twofold axis,
and the only nontrivial
operation there is a rotation
through 180 degrees.
So this an axis A pi.
And again, the ground rules
are that if we're to add a
mirror plane to this axis,
which along with identity
constitutes a group, we can't
create any new axes.
So there are two ways
we can do this.
One is the three-dimensional
analog of something that we
have already done, namely to
pass a mirror plane through
the twofold axis.
And this is the group that we
found as a two-dimensional
Point Group, and we
called it 2mm.
And to do that, we used the
theorem that says that if you
take a rotation operation A
alpha and combine it with a
reflection operation that goes
through it, you get a new
reflection plane, sigma prime,
that's at an angle alpha over
2 to the first.
So what gave us the second
mirror line in two dimensions,
in three dimensions that would
give us another mirror plane
that's at right angles
to the first.
And this will give us a
three-dimensional symmetry,
which is also called 2mm.
So it's nothing more than taking
the two- dimensional
Point Group and letting it come
out at the board at you--
Man, that'll give you nightmares
when these things
are coming out of the
paper at you--
and that is a valid group 2mm.
There's another way that we can
add a mirror plane to a
rotation axis though which will
not create any new axes,
and that's to add the mirror
plane-- the reflection
operation sigma I should say
since it is a combinations of
operations--
exactly perpendicular
to the locus of
the rotation operation.
And that reflection operation
sigma then just flips the
rotation axis end to end.
And the rotation operation just
swirls the locus of the
reflection plane around within
its own locus and doesn't
create any new reflection
plane.
So in the particular combination
A pi, if we add a
mirror plane perpendicular to
that as the operation sigma,
this would be then all of the
operations of a twofold axis
over all of the operations
of a mirror plane.
So we've got now a combination
of a twofold axis with a
mirror plane.
We've got the same thing here.
To distinguish these two
combinations, we'll write this
as a fraction 2/m.
And that literally in words
is the way we've added the
twofold axis.
It is sitting over the mirror
plane and gets reflected down
into its other end when the
mirror plane act on.
So it's just language.
It's nice though, as we said
some weeks ago, if our
language have some descriptive
content to so when we look at
it we can remind ourselves
of what it means.
So two 2mm means the mirror
planes are parallel to the
axis that contain it.
2/m means the twofold axis
is over the mirror plane.
It goes through and
pierces it.
What I would like to
ask though is have
we got a group yet?
And let's take a
first object--
let's call it right handed--
rotate it by 180 degrees.
You get a second one, which
will stay right handed.
And then repeat it by a
reflection operation in the
mirror plane, and we'll
get a third operation.
Reflection changes
chirality, so the
third one is left handed.
So we are performing the
sequence of operations A pi
followed by sigma.
And let me append just so we
make no mistake and not
confuse it with 2mm that the
reflection operation is normal
to the mirror plane.
So question, what is
the net effect?
And lo and behold, we have
stumbled over-- if we had not
been clever enough to invented
it and suggested it early on--
the only way you can get from 1
to 3 in one shot is to turn
it inside out and change its
chirality by projecting it
through a point which is the
location where the twofold
rotation pierces the
mirror plane.
And what this is going to do is
to change the sense of all
three coordinates.
This is going to take the
coordinates XYZ of object
number 1 and change them into
minus x, minus y, minus c.
And what we're doing is
inverting the motif, turning
it inside out as it were,
into an enantiomorph.
And we have discovered as soon
as we combine a pi with a
perpendicular reflection plane,
a new operation which
we'll call in words inversion.
And the symbol that used to
describe this is a one with a
bar over it, and we'll
see why later on.
But this is a onefold axis
with an inversion center
sitting on it, and that's
what an inversion
center by itself is.
The implication is that they're
going to be other axes
that we can abbreviate such as
3-bar, 4-bar, and so on.
So this is analogous to a
situation that will come later
where we really need
a new notation.
So we've fell headlong over
a new type of symmetry
operation, and we should
consider taking inversion and
adding that to the
rotation axes by
themselves as an extender.
Obviously, if we take inversion
and add it to a
mirror plane, we're
going to get A pi.
If we take a twofold rotation,
add it perpendicular to a
mirror plane, we
get inversion.
If we put inversion and put it
on a 180-degree rotation,
we'll get the mirror
plane back.
So these things all permute
one to another.
You may even remember some time
ago we asked in general
terms when do two operations
permute
without changing anything.
And the answer is if these
operations to leave the locus
of the other one alone.
And the mirror plane obviously
leaves the locus of the
rotation operation unchanged.
The rotation operation spins the
mirror plane around in its
own plane and doesn't
create a new axis.
And the inversion center leaves
the mirror plane alone
and takes the twofold
axis top to bottom.
So those three operations,
inversion A pi, sigma are the
three nontrivial operations
that exist in the space.
The fourth one is the
identity operation.
So here is the set of elements
in the group that
we will call 2/m.
2/m implies three operations
inversion, a 180-degree
rotation, reflection in a plane
perpendicular to the
axis, and the identity
operation.
And I'll leave it to yourself
for you to convince yourself
that I can rotate and then
reflect or I can reflect and
then invert.
And all of these operations
do not create any new
motifs in the set.
The group multiplication
table, in other words,
contains just the four
elements, 1,
1-bar, A pi, and sigma.
So the full pattern that
corresponds to 2/m consists of
four objects.
It'll be a fourth
one down here.
The twofold axis tells you
have this fellow is
related to this one.
Inversion tells you how this
one is related to this one.
And the mirror plane tells you
how this one, number 1, is
related to number 4.
And the identity operation
tells you how 1
is related to itself.
So, again, as we've seen in
the set of operations that
constitute a group, there's a
one-to-one correspondence
between the transformations that
are elements of the group
and the number of objects
in the pattern.
So we've made one combination,
and what we found from this is
a new transformation inversion
that involves changing the
sign of all the coordinates in
a space through a point which
is called the inversion
center.
Questions?
If not, let me quickly rattle
off other Point
Groups in this family.
We could take the operation A
pi/2 in 90-degree rotation and
add this perpendicular
to mirror plane.
Let me now say something
that I've said
again many times before.
The pattern of objects that will
result is the pattern of
objects that's produced
by the initial group--
let's say a fourfold axis--
repeated by the extender.
And the operation sigma
perpendicular is the extender.
So the pattern, without making
any big deal about it, is
going to look like this square
of objects reflected down
below the mirror plane.
So it'll be one going
down like this.
One like this.
The operation A pi sits
perpendicular to the operation
of reflection, so there will
be an inversion center that
arises at the point
of intersection.
And indeed the square above
can be inverted
through this point--
little hasty repairs there--
and every one up above gets
inverted down to an
enantiomorph below.
So all of these guys up on
top are right handed.
All these guys down below
are left handed.
So this is another group.
This is 4/m in international
notation, a fourfold axis
perpendicular to
a mirror plane.
There is also, unfortunately,
a Schoenflies notation.
The international notation tells
you what you've got, a
twofold axis or a fourfold axis
perpendicular to a mirror plane.
The Schoenflies notation tells
you how you derived it.
And the symbol for a twofold
axis is C2, so this is a
twofold axis.
And what we did was to add an
extender consisting of a
horizontal mirror plane.
Schoenflies calls this one
C2h; Group C2, which is a
twofold axis; a horizontal
m is the extender.
So Schoenflies tells you
how you make it.
The international notation
tells you what
you get as a result.
Schoenflies notation here would
be C4, that's the symbol
for a fourfold axis, and
the extender is an h.
And then without making any big
fuss about it, if I do the
same with a sixfold axis, I will
have six objects related
by a sixfold rotation axis.
If I take that sixfold axis
and put a mirror plane
perpendicular to it, these will
be reflected down to a
hexagon of enantiomorph
equidistant
below the mirror plane.
That's not terribly good, but
it's not terribly bad either.
So this would be called 6/m,
Schoenflies notation C6h.
And the operation A pi exists in
a sixfold axis, so there is
an inversion center but also
arises as a new symmetry
element at the point
of intersection.
So with reckless abandon, you
can continue on here and
derive noncrystallographic
groups for all the even-fold
axes and derive an 8/m
and a 12/m and 16/m.
Lovely symmetries.
I wouldn't want to draw them,
but they're still symmetries.
They all have an inversion
center in them, but they're
noncrystallographic.
So we don't have to worry about
them for prism purposes.
I left one out because it
introduces a complication that
is kind of curious
and interesting.
Any questions on what
we've done here?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The 2mm, it's
just the same--
Schoenflies notation
is just C2--
PROFESSOR: Schoenflies notation
for three dimensions
is exactly the same as in two.
So the three-dimensional version
where this extends in
a direction that is normal to
the two-dimensional space of
our two dimensions.
Two dimensions it was this.
Now just imagine them coming out
of the blackboard at you.
The symbol for this
one was 2mm.
The symbol for this one is
also 2mm, the same thing.
The mirror plane is a vertical
mirror plane.
So the Schoenflies notation is
exactly the same as what we
used per two dimensions.
It's called C2v.
We've added a vertical
mirror plane.
And again, horizontal
and vertical.
Horizontal is horizontal
with respect to the
axis of higher symmetry.
Vertical is vertical with
respect to the two-dimensional
space of the two-dimensional
Point Group, parallel to the
axis in three dimensions.
So that's the vertical
indication.
So let's, though, tuck that
away for future reference.
We've got two kinds
of extenders.
We've got a horizontal mirror
plane, and we've got a
vertical mirror plane, and these
are extenders that we
should consider adding.
So we've taken care of
2/m, 4/m and 6/m.
2mm, 3m, 4mm, and 6mm are just
the extensions into a third
dimension of what we've seen
and come to love in the
two-dimensional space.
Let me now turn to the
threefold axis.
And this is a curious one.
Threefold axes require fewer
symbols to indicate the
vertical mirror planes
because there's only
one independent one.
But let's see what
would happen.
And now I'm not going to attempt
to draw these in three
dimensions anymore.
I'm going to use a stereographic
projection.
And what I'll do is use a solid
dot for a point that's
up above the equatorial plane
and an open dot for one that's
down below the equatorial
plane.
So my stereographic projection
of 4mm would look like.
This is the fourfold axis.
This is the mirror plane.
And I've got one up that gets
reproduced by the axis to give
me a set of four.
All of these are, let's
say, right handed.
And then directly below them
is another set of four
repeated by reflection, and
these are all left handed.
And then there's an inversion
center at the point of
intersection.
And I'll indicate that by the
little open circle sitting
right on the fourfold axis.
So there is a projection
of what 4/m looks like.
So let me now do the same thing
for a threefold axis.
And I'll add to the triangle
of points that a threefold
axis would generate.
So these guys are all
of one chirality.
Let's say right handed.
Then I'll reflect them down,
and I'll get three objects
that are down.
And that's what 3/m
looks like.
Is there an inversion
center here?
No.
No, because the operation
of A pi is missing.
And it was the horizontal mirror
plane combined with A
pi that gave us the inversion
center with all of the even
rotation axis.
So one of the things we have to
say here is that there is
no 1-bar that's present, which
means in this instance, unlike
the other ones, we have
another option.
So we can use the operation of
inversion as an extender too.
So we're going to get another
group out of the threefold
axis besides this one.
And this one we will
name 3/m or C3h
in Schoenflies notation.
They're six objects here, so
there should be six operations
in the group.
So let me number these guys
up on top as number 1,
number 2, number 3.
And 1 is related to itself
by inversion.
There's an operation A 2 pi/3.
And that tells me how the one
that's up is related to the
second one that's up and how
the left-handed one that's
down is related to the
one that's directly
below number 2.
There is an operation
A 4 pi/3.
And that's the same as saying
8 minus 2 pi/3.
And that tells us how the things
that are separated by
240 degrees are related,
both up and down.
I know how 3 up is related to 3
down and how 1 up is related
to 1 down and 2 up is
related to 2 down.
This is all with the horizontal
mirror plane, which
I'll call sigma h.
That is a total of one,
two, three, four--
whoops-- one, two, three
four operations.
I need six.
Let's ask how is this one that's
up related to this one
that's down?
I just got rotation operations
and reflection.
The only way I can get from this
one number 1 to this one
number 3 left that's down is
to take two steps to do it.
I can't get from this one up
here to this one down here
unless I rotate 60 degrees
and then invert.
If I move over to 3-bar.
This is A 2 pi/3 with 1-bar
as an extender.
The pattern would, again,
look like what are
threefold axis does.
But then if I repeat this set of
three by inversion, the two
triangles above and
below are skewed.
The ones down below
are enantiomorphs.
The three that are up are
of opposite chirality.
And this is a new
type of pattern.
And in international notation,
what do we call this?
It's a threefold axis.
But how do we indicate a
symbol for three with
inversion sitting on it?
Let's ask if we know how each of
these objects is related to
each of the other.
So here's 1, 2, and 3; 1 goes to
2 by A 2 pi/3; 1 goes to 3
by A minus 2 pi/3.
Let's put some numbers on here
for the ones down below.
Let's call them 4, 5, and 6;
1 goes to 6 by an version.
How do I get from 1 up
to 4 that's down?
I can do that only by
taking two steps.
Rotate 1 from here
to number 2.
Don't yet put it down.
First invert it.
So 1 to 4 involves the operation
A 2 pi/3 followed
immediately by inversion.
And I go from 1 up to 5 down by
doing the operation A minus
2 pi/3 followed immediately
by inversion.
And then 1 goes to
1 and itself by
the identity operation.
So I have six objects, one, two,
three, four, five, six
operations.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In the cases where
you're rotating and inverting,
does it matter which
way to the other?
PROFESSOR: No, it shouldn't
because they
leave each other alone.
So I can rotate from here
to here and invert.
Or I can invert from here
to here and then rotate.
It's the same transformation.
Again, they permute if the two
loci of the two operations
leave the other locus alone.
Maybe the enormity of what
we've shown here
has not sunk in.
This is a new two-step
operation.
We can't describe it any simpler
than saying, rotate
and not put it down yet,
follow up by inversion.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: Couldn't we express
that in another way by sort of
extending the three-directional
glide plane
by saying invert, then transform
by some vector
that's parallel to
the glide plane?
PROFESSOR: Maybe they do in
space group, but as soon as we
introduce a glide plane, you've
got an operation that's
half a lattice translation.
And that means you've got to
have a lattice translation and
double the lattice
translation, so--
AUDIENCE: Oh, we don't have
to worry about that.
PROFESSOR: --when we're in
a space group, yeah.
That could be present.
But not for a point group
because the ground rules are
at least one point
has to remain
immutably fixed in space.
So this is a two-step operation,
and what we're
going to call it is
rotoinversion.
It consists of as a first step
an operation by rotating alpha
from 0.1 to a virtual
point number 2.
But before you put it down, you
will invert it to a new
object number 2 which is
of opposite chirality.
So here then are the operation
of the group that results when
you combine a threefold rotation
axis and add to it an
version center as an extended;
A 2 pi/3; A minus 2 pi/3; a
rotoinversion operation through
2 pi/3 and then
inverting; a rotoinversion
operation of A minus 2 pi/3
followed by inversion.
And the symbol that is used to
represent that new two-step
operation is putting a bar
over the top of the
symbol for the axis.
And then, finally, we have
inversion by itself.
So that's a group rank 6.
The Schoenflies notation is
called C3i because we got this
group by adding an inversion
to C3, the threefold axis.
The international notation picks
up on putting a bar over
an axis to indicate a
rotoinversion operation.
So this is called 3-bar in the
international notation.
So there is a new group,
and it is an oddball.
It sort of stands alone
from the other
groups of the form C3h.
This we derived by using the
rotation of the threefold axis
and adding 1-bar
as an extender.
So there's no mirror
plane in this.
AUDIENCE: That's not
the same as--
PROFESSOR: That's the
same as 3/m, no.
3/m is C3h.
3-bar is C3i, different extender
added to the same
subgroup 3C.
AUDIENCE: What was the
definition of 3/m?
PROFESSOR: Oh, we never
really finished that.
That if we need the six
operations that control the
group, we'll have a sixfold
rotoinversion axis.
But this pattern looks just like
the triangle produced by
3, and we add an reflection
operation as an inversion, and
the 3 go down.
So if we ask how every one of
the top is related to one
underneath, that's by this
horizontal mirror plane.
If I want to know how I get
from this one that's up to
this one that's down, then I've
got to rotate through 60
degrees and invert.
So that would be a rotoinversion
operation.
Let us to extend this idea of
a rotoinversion operation.
And we would find this
eventually in adding different
extenders and falling headlong
over this rotoinversion
operation as we did
here with 3-bar.
But let me in this case start by
defining a 4-bar operation.
And this would contain the
operation A pi/2 followed
immediately by inversion.
And we'll call this
step A pi/2-bar.
So let's try to do that
and see what we get.
Start with a first
point, number 1.
And that's up, so it's
a solid dot.
And let's say it's
right handed.
If we combine that with a
rotation of 90 degrees.
Not yet put it down.
That's a virtual motif.
Before putting it down,
we inverted it.
We would get one that's down,
and it would be left handed.
Do the operation again.
I'll put the little
tadpole inside.
Do the operation again.
Rotate 90 degrees and invert.
We're back up again.
So this was 1.
This is 2.
This was 3.
And that's up.
Do the operation again.
Rotate and invert.
And here is number
4, and it's down.
Do it a fifth time, and we're
back to where we started.
So this is a crazy pattern.
It's a pair of objects that's
up and a pair of objects
that's down.
So there's a twofold
axis in there.
That twofold axis A pi leave
the pattern invariant.
But there is no way of
specifying the relation
between the two that are up
and the two that are down
other than doing this two-step
process of rotating 90 degrees
and then inverting.
So there is actually in this
pattern a new type of
operation analogous to 3-bar,
and it's called a 4-bar axis.
And it's indicated geometrically
by drawing a
square because there's
a 90-degree
angular symmetry to this.
But a twofold axis inscribed
inside of it because this is a
pattern that has a
twofold symmetry.
So something that has this
symmetry is the symmetry of a
tetrahedron.
And if we draw a line from the
upper edge to the lower edge,
this is the locus
of a 4-bar axis.
International notation
this is called 4-bar.
That's how we generated
the pattern.
The Schoenflies notation is an
S, little bit of exotica.
This geometric solid
is something
that's called a sphenoid.
And sphenoid.
Is the Greek word for axe.
And you can imagine a handle
put onto this thing, and it
does look kind of like an axe.
You could splits firewood
with a thing like that.
It looks like a tetrahedron,
but in a tetrahedron, it's
either elongated along the
4-bar axis are squished.
It doesn't have to be regular.
So this is called S4, and the
S stands for sphenoid.
AUDIENCE: Is it part of
a regular tetrahedron?
PROFESSOR: No, no.
A regular tetrahedron would be
something where all of the
edges had equal length.
And what we're doing is taking
one edge and the edge that's
opposite it and either
stretching it or squishing it.
So there are two edges.
This one, and this one, which
are the same length.
And then these four inclined
edges have a different length.
It could be either elongated
or squished.
But it's not a regular
tetrahedron.
If those three distances were
equal, then geometrically it
would be a tetrahedron.
But strictly speaking, a
tetrahedron is not a
tetrahedron, just as a square
prism with eight sides
approximately equal can't claim
to be a cube unless
there's symmetry present that
demands that this be true.
In this case, the 4-bar requires
that these four edges
inclined to the 4-bar axis
be of one length.
And this have to have
the same length.
But there's nothing that
constrains all six to the
edges to be of identical
length.
So it's not a tetrahedron,
so squished or deformed
tetrahedron.
So there is another two-step
symmetry element that we would
not have been clever enough to
think of had we not discovered
this sort of rotoinversion
operation when we added
inversion to a threefold axis.
A 3-bar axis is a step that's
present when you add inversion
to a threefold axis.
So 3-bar, what we call it for
short, is identical to a
threefold axis plus inversion
sitting on it.
A 4-bar is not equal to a
fourfold axis with inversion
added to it.
A 4-bar is something that you
cannot describe any more
simply than saying there is a
two-step operation in there,
and it's a group of rank 4.
Let me finish by setting up the
task of going through this
systematically.
We have 11 axial combinations
1, 2, 3, 4, 6, 222, 32, 422,
622, 23, and 432.
So there are 11 of those.
We want to examine as extenders
a vertical mirror
plane that would be
one extender.
We should add that to each
of these symmetries.
We already done a
lot of these.
We've done pretty
much up here.
We could add a horizontal
mirror plane.
Or we've encountered inversion
when we added a mirror plane
perpendicular to an
even-fold axis.
We could add inversion
as an extender.
And to be complete, we should
add to our list of axes in
quotation marks, the 4-bar axis,
having discovered it.
And does that do it?
Is there anything else we could
do to these axes that
would leave them invariant?
.
AUDIENCE: What about 2-bar?
PROFESSOR: 2-bar; 2-bar
would be rotate
180 degrees and invert.
So 2-bar is identical to a
horizontal mirror plane.
So that's nothing new.
We're already running a
little over time so--
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: 3-bar?
PROFESSOR: 3-bar is 3 plus
1, and we call at 3i, so
this one down here.
This is 3-bar.
We describe it for short as
that, but it really is a
threefold axis with
an inversion
center sitting on it.
This thing is distinct because
it's not a fourfold axis with
inversion sitting on it.
A 4-bar is a 4-bar is a 4-bar.
You can't decompose it as a
twofold axis is a subgroup.
That's only half the story.
I don't want to keep you
anxious, not anxious to find
out what the answer is
but anxious to get on
your way and go home.
So let me submit that when we
have more than one rotation
axis, such as 222 or as in 32,
if we put the mirror plane in
normal to the principal axis,
we'll call that a horizontal
mirror plane.
If we add the mirror plane
through the principal axis, we
could pass it through the
threefold axis and the twofold
axis, pass it through the
vertical twofold axis and the
horizontal twofold axis.
We will call this a vertical
mirror plane.
And that's all we could say for
a single axis, the mirror
plane was perpendicular to the
axis or passed through it.
But when there's more than one
axis, another thing we could
do would be to snake the mirror
plane in between the
twofold axis.
In that case, this
twofold axis gets
reflected into this one.
But I haven't created
any new axes.
So that is going to leave
the results of Euler's
construction unchanged.
I can't similarly put a vertical
mirror plane through
this first twofold axis but
in between the other two.
In that case, this is no longer
222 because these two
mirror planes are equivalent
by reflection, so I want to
drop that at very least.
So in any case, without
belaboring
the point, it's late.
I could do for each of the
groups that involved more than
one axis I could add a diagonal
mirror plane, or I
should try to add a diagonal
mirror planes.
And this means interleaved
between axes that are present
in these combinations,
added such that
no new axis is created.
But the addition clearly is
going to be a new disposition
of symmetry elements
arranged in any
different fashion and space.
So the game's afoot.
This is what remains
to be done next.
What I'll do for next time is
prepare a chart that looks
like this that has the results
of all of the unique
combinations shown and then
hand out pictures of
stereographic projections
of all the results.
I think once you know how to
play the game to go through
and do every single
one in detail is
probably not necessary.
If you know how to do some of
them and you know all the
tricks for adding extenders, you
could do it if you had to.
All right.
So, again, sorry we started late
and sorry that we last
long as well.